Is a Rithertall okay to use monk most monk fruit has a Rithertall in it. So Rithertall is a sugar alcohol
And sugar alcohols really came into use
During the days, I was probably was of 15 20 years ago and that I was that diet going around where the guy was supposed to be really
I was kind of like the
Kind of like a keto diet, but he wasn't getting anybody to keep toast. That wasn't the purpose and
Forgot his name starts with a pee I think
But it was eating you know more like carnivore diet
But it wasn't really a responsible carnivore diet. He did a whole lot of fat and and
But the people were losing weight like crazy because they just were eating carbs
But you know if you have sweet tooth, what are you gonna eat you know to satisfy your sweet tooth? Well, that's where the sugar alcohols
really came into use
And they were put into like protein bars and all that kind of stuff and
You know, there's a lot of studies on sugar alcohols and what they do the benefit is is they don't
For the most part they don't spike your glucose levels
But they have other negatives to them. So
Spawn that they can disrupt
different metabolic processes and
Long-term use of them could cause all sorts of problems
But for the most part, it's in fairly high-calcitation of use
so
You know, that's why I think in our binder. I'd have some
information about using sugar alcohols in general
It's it all has to do with that, you know
With quantity like so many things have to do with quantity
you know if
Off it's okay to use that then we're gonna use that in everything and we're gonna you know eat
tons of milligrams of sugar alcohols will then over time if you do that every day it can cause issues
But having you know that once in a while it's not gonna be a problem
It's certainly not gonna be a problem as far as a driver of the cancer. So it can be out you can lead to other health care
issues
High dose use of it over a long period of time
But I've not seen any data that shows that sugar alcohols promote cancer growth
Or it certainly doesn't break down to glucose. It is used as a fuel source
by the mitochondria. So
And by cancer cells. So it I know it's not gonna be an issue with cancer
So yeah, you're safe to use that you're safe to use sugar substitutes
You're safe to use
sugars that break down the slower, you know
and
There's you know, there's the idea is you're not getting these glucose spikes
When you eat something when you get these glucose spikes when you eat something it's just
fuel for our cancer
To pick up and to gobble on so that's what we're trying to be careful of
Is those glucose spikes sugar alcohols don't do that
So they can't be a good substitute for a sweet tooth somebody stayed away from sugar trying to be on a ketogenic type nine